this week NBC made an announcement they
announced that their next live musical
telecast will be the Wiz that's a big
announcement NBC yeah they're gonna do a
telecast of The Wiz they've already had
success with the live versions of The
Sound of Music that was a big hit and
last year's Peter Pan which starred
Allison Williams and Christopher Walken
as Captain Hook
well anyway The Wiz is going to feature
performers from Cirque de Soleil which
means you're gonna really hello hello
Colin yes hello who's this it's me
Christopher Walken okay what can I do
for you make it quick
no cuz for you called me oh that's great
I'm glad I did because I have a question
where do I go for this Wiz gig what the
ways on NBC I'm ready to go I've got my
pirate outfit on there's no pirate in
the Wiz oh good so they haven't cast it
yet no no no now there's no pirate in
this story at all it's based on The
Wizard of Oz oh come on Conan you can
get me in there pull some strings what
strings can I pull come on you're hot
property over the peacock you and the
friends guys the friends get no that was
a while ago and that Jerry sign Berg
he's hilarious
oh and that show with George Clooney oh
no you mean er mr. Walken I've been on
TV yet I've been on TBS for the past
five years
you're on TBS well if the doctor said
you need it you should keep taking out
watch the dosage though that stuff
messed me up good in the late 70s sounds
like it yeah no it's not a drug it's a
TV network a TV network Wow that reminds
me can you get me a pot on NBC's the
ways no the whiz has an african-american
cast
oh no problem I can play black with a
little makeup no no that's a bad idea
better little grease paint would do the
trick then you can imagine a white man
performing and singing as a black man
yeah it'll blow people's mind it will
blow their minds yeah no no no trust me
you do not want to do that
I'm very convincing as a black guy did
you see Kevin Hart's stand-up special
yes yes I did
that was me okay no no it wasn't April
Fool's okay no you didn't fool me why
did you call me no you called me well
I'm glad I did do you think you could
pull some strings and get me into the
Wiz hey no forget it
[Applause]
the big question how does the hook hold
the phone that's the big question
you